rex chapman former nba player kentucky
star
and he uh wrote an article it was in the
lexington herald leader and the headline
is injustice double standards in
heartbreaking bigotry rex chapman on
race
in america rex kind enough to join us
from kentucky this morning
rex what made you write it
oh man dave uh dan sorry i've been on
17 different zooms recently um
you know i was asked a few questions the
other day after
uh george floyd's murder and
it took me three or four days to just
put my
put my thoughts together uh and i i
really don't want to
speak too off the cuff on about this
stuff right now just because i think
i've said what i've said
um and it's probably a little bit above
my pay grade
i i'm i'm just a basketball a former
basketball
player i grew up with uh black and white
friends and
all of this has just been absolutely
heartbreaking i feel a little bit broken
dre drew brees's comments yesterday
didn't help
did and certainly didn't help me feel
any better i can't imagine it
made any of his peers feel any better so
we're going through a tough time and i
i do think and this sounds just awful to
it
say out loud but it's going to take
white people with voices in order to
to help help get us past
get us past this or at least make it
somewhat
more bearable right now this is uh
i've not seen anything like this and i
grew up i was born in the 60s grew up
in kentucky for 18 years
and so i know
i know it from a personal level but i
don't know it from
i'm i'm i'm white i'm white i don't
if we're not listening to what you know
our black friends people of color are
saying right now and we just have our
our opinions we're not going to make any
any progress
yeah i i have echoed those same
sentiments that we move on so quickly
in our society that we
it wasn't long ago where you had an
unarmed
uh black man who was just jogging in a
community
in a neighborhood in atlanta or georgia
and got shot
murdered we moved on and then you know
eric garner i can't breathe like we just
move
on and that's if we continue to move on
then
none of this is gonna matter it feels
like and that's the sad part of all of
this
yeah um i don't know dan i'm
i'm i'm a little bit of a at a loss uh
i don't know i don't know i'm i'm i'm
at a loss for words right now sorry but
it hit you pretty hard here
yeah here's here's here's one thing i
don't understand we
we pay and i i've started noticing this
when i was young
we encourage our kids to go play and do
and and
watch sports be like that guy be like
that guy entertainers
we'll spend our hard-earned money on
season tickets
to go to these games and we worship our
black athletes and entertainers
but don't bring them home don't come
home to date my son and daughter
and that to me that to me
is one of the it's one of the saddest
things
that i've seen in my lifetime um
i don't know i don't know how we get
past that you grew up in ohio i grew up
in kentucky
and i know a lot of people that feel
like white people are just supposed to
marry white people and that's the way it
goes and if you date a black person or
you
you marry a black person you're marked
you know this and i know this
you're marked what is that what was the
reaction when you were dating
an african-american when you're at
kentucky
not not pleasant not pleasant i mean
and you're the star of the basketball
team
yeah yeah uh
it was all real real confusing look i
was just coming to school to play
basketball and and be myself and i'd
grown up
i grew up with white kids and black kids
from the time i was seven or eight years
old
my dad played basketball and his friends
many of his friends um
lived in the projects in owensboro so i
would be dropped off down there and
hang with my friends in the projects
play basketball it's where i learned to
play basketball
um i've lost my train of thought
i'm sorry you know what let me let me
change topics here thanks
unless would you rather not do this
because i
no i want to be respectful i look i i
know it's
yeah no look man it this is stuff that
needs to be talked about
um my point was i was just going to play
basketball i was a teenager and i didn't
think about
the the basketball part for me was very
easy at kentucky very easy
i mean aside from all the conditioning
and stuff you do when you when you get
to school
the actual basketball park was easy it
was the other stuff that was hard
trying to live up to and look not only
to uh what people wanted me to do
with my dating but you know look i
didn't care about school
i didn't and i should have but i didn't
i could make good grades but i they
wanted me
you know people wanted me to be the
all-american guy make good grades be
you know all academic and just
sort of portray that all american image
and i've struggled with that my whole
life because i'm not that guy
i'm not that guy i'm just i'm just me
i'm not trying to be
what you want me to be um i'm just
trying to be myself and i
honest to goodness you know dan i got in
trouble for shoplifting a few years ago
and it
again that's it's hard for me to even
say that you know me or you've known
me forever i've never been in trouble i
went down a path of addiction
to where i actually stole something
but nobody's ever called me a thug
nobody and i played with teammates for
years who
were portrayed as thugs
not a one of them had ever gotten in
trouble you know i
my feeling on it was that it was
it's not about thuggish behavior
it's about whether you've got tats and
cornrows
and that bothers me i played with sev
several guys my whole career in and out
with and against who really the media
always ah he's a thug
he's a thug or people would say that and
it couldn't have been further
further from the truth you know just had
cornrows maybe some tats
uh maybe dreads i don't know
i do know that people are afraid of
things they don't really understand and
i i've never understood
how you can look at someone and not
actually want to get to know him and
listen we can generalize all we want dan
you never truly know a person's pain
until you've sat and talked with
that individual person yeah you just
you don't know what their what their
pain is we're talking to rex chapman
former nba player former kentucky star
um
i go back and i looked at video that was
painful for me to see that video of you
shoplifting and i'm going i
i i had been with you and
i i came in that day and i just
i said that can't be the guy that i yeah
i've known for a long
time like socialize with you i i just i
i
and then look we have people that are
close to us who
have been addicts or there's an
addiction or drinking or whatever it's
pills
and i just said you're no different than
anybody else you're susceptible to this
but
god lee i i still i can't believe that's
you in that video
i know man and you know i walked around
for
many years just kind of numb from from
the painkillers
um but yeah i
uh i don't know i don't know this is
difficult
i'm glad i'll be ready for us to talk
horseradish
and basketball and maybe even john
calipari to the lakers at some point
there you go
there you go
oh i love that when all of a sudden i'm
going
oh rex has calipari going to the lakers
[Laughter]
man did you catch grief oh man did i but
you know what
the positive about that was i was so
messed up on the painkillers i didn't
really think about it
uh no names here yeah
what's the best recruiting enticement
you got because you're one of the you
were one of the
great high school players in america you
don't have to name names
yeah you don't have to tell me what
kentucky gave you but
what is the best enticement you got
coming out of high school
yeah i don't i don't really know what
you're talking about
sarcastically yes of course
hypothetically what could have been the
nicest thing
hypothetically one of the sweetest
things and i'll go ahead and say this
because i don't even
i don't think it was a recruiting
violation uh
back in the day uh
you know wildcat lodge where
the the players stay and kentucky
basketball players lucky basketball dorm
um for a while it was just
players in there but then the ncaa said
no this place is too nice you've got to
have
regular students in there as well so
regular students stay downstairs i don't
know a dozen of them
but i put my two of my best friends
kevin and keith vanderpool they're twins
grew up we played peewee football
together high school basketball together
everything
they came and lived in the lodge
wait that's not juicy come on
what do you want somebody offer did
somebody on for your car
i don't know that's a yes i don't know
no
no no a bag of cash nobody offered me
anything did somebody offer somebody you
knew something
[Laughter]
did you ever get a 100 handshake at
kentucky rex
chapman from my mom and dad oh
boy you're dead your dad didn't have a
hundred dollars
no because he lost he bet the pick six
at ellis park
previously by the way rex went hardship
back then right when you went early you
went
hardship there no we you and i joke
about that you know
but let's think about that a little bit
right
at this point in time with all the race
stuff yeah
we joke about that oh there's a label
attached to you
it is but but also it's a label it used
to be
what did it used to mean dan you tell me
well that you didn't have money that you
had to help out your family
right right and the reason
it's interesting that i went hardship
it's not because of it's really not
because my
we didn't have a lot of money we really
didn't
but ever almost everyone else who's ever
gone hardship
is black you and i joke about it
and it is kind of funny and all that i
went hardship
you know you leave early now but
hardship back in the day meant
you know something different i think i
was trying to think how many
white players went hardship you know
only one that i could think of in my and
i don't know if you know you probably
do do know this i i remember finding out
one day
i was getting ready to play the dallas
mavericks i was
18 or not 19 or 20 years old rookie
and uh i was looking through the game
notes and saw where
uh you know studying kind of my
match-ups and whatnot for the night
came across brad davis remember brad
davis
yeah left early i never knew that did he
go hardship
well what else do you go well i don't
know i just wasn't he
left before he left maryland yes he left
before his elegance okay
yeah yeah i just remember you went
hardship
i don't remember brad davis going
hardship right it's interesting
yeah so i mean not a lot but there's one
now
uh that i know of and that's tyler hero
yeah tyler hero by the way you played
good defense for a change
uh on the kentucky questions that was
and you never played defense
yeah that's very true yeah that's very
good they must have loved when they
they probably circled it when they were
playing the hornets like uh oh
oh go like george jordan probably
went uh who do i oh i got oh i got rex
chapman
yeah that's right that's right works
better
better guard me on the other end though
whoa okay
uh what did you think of the jordan
documentary loved it couldn't get enough
of it
um you know i know michael's taking some
grief over this but
i got to tell you he was different man
he was different and uh could you have
been his teammate
yes i would have loved to do you know
this
this is a something that's also
heartbreaking for me to think about
sports-wise michael had gone to play
baseball
and i i i was kind of coming in my own
in washington
and was having a really good year in
fact i was about to make the all-star
team and the day that they announced the
all-stars
uh i dislocated my ankle prior to that
there was a deal that was basically
almost done
for me to go to chicago for ron harper
and ron had come in michael's absence
and
you know he was kind of limping around
and just he couldn't really
score like he used to and
so then i dislocated my ankle
they kept ron michael came back and they
went on this whole
whole damn thing so my story's
way more tragic than you know
oh but i'll i'll say this dan mike
michael called me in high school for
dean to go to carolina he was probably
first or second year player in the
league and that was cool and everything
but then we
we had the same agent forever david fall
wait wait so
jordan calls you you're a senior in high
school
yeah junior a junior in high school yeah
and he says
like like how does that so mom picks up
the phone and goes oh no
better it's even better back in the day
there's only a landline
you know in your house and uh me and my
sister she's a year
younger you know the phone was a whole
big deal
and every time recruiters called the the
the rule for my sister jenny was jenny
had to get off the phone
if a recruiter called in so she hated me
and hated the whole thing
and uh michael dean had told me michael
was gonna be calling and
i was home but the phone rang i guess
she was on the phone
and she clicks over and says hello and
he says hi uh this is michael jordan can
i talk to rex
and she hung up on it
how did you turn so now you know why
michael lit you up that one night
because you turned down carolina he
holds grudges rex
no man but the thing about that i go to
kentucky and then i signed with david
and then
michael and i became friends and we
played golf together we'd go bowling
together and what not and what i want to
say
um is that you saw the interviews that
michael gave in high school
and that he gave you know a couple years
there at
uh carolina i'm proud of him man
i'm proud of where he's come from and
what he's done he didn't have to figure
out the media like
i do some journeyman nba slept around
the
the league he had to learn how to be
polished on camera and and say
things and not be inflammatory he's
worked hard to
to get where he's gotten and yeah i know
he takes a lot of grief and maybe
rightfully so at some point i love that
man
i love michael jordan but i'll tell you
one other little
little story quickly
he beat me almost every time we ever
played
my first year my year in miami we we
beat them
flukey game i got 38 or 39
the year they went 72 and 10. and
we we beat them at our place they ended
up sweeping us
like we were a jv team in the first
round of the playoffs but this is
regular season and i
had a big game and we they partied all
night on south beach
and i know they did because i was there
and so um i had a big game
and we played them again regular season
game again about two weeks later
jump ball and again michael and our
friends
you know we will play on the floor and
all that but i almost never beat him
almost never and as soon as the ball was
thrown up
that next meeting as soon as the ball
went in the air
he went crack and elbowed me right in
the sternum
right in and i went oh and and and then
said
ah [ __ ] it's gonna be like this tonight
and guess what it was it was he played i
think he got like 35 and didn't play the
fourth quarter and i got like 13 on
three for 30.
so he was apologizing in advance of
putting a beating on you
yeah well no he he didn't i said it's
going to be like that tonight in my head
i was like oh [ __ ] and and
and uh it was you know and then i got a
good full dose of it in three
playoff games where he was all business
in championship mode
so he's the best i've ever played wit uh
played against
he's just different just different hey i
love you
thanks for making us laugh and uh
we'll talk yeah all right thanks dad
that's uh
rex chapman former nba uh player and uh
kentucky star